search and rescue operations continued
sunday evening nearly for full full days
after
champlain tower south partially
collapsed in surfside florida
nine people are confirmed that 150 to
unaccounted for as search and rescue
operations continues sunday
evening almost for four days after a
12-story condominium building collapse
in florida
chaplain south towers tower south
partially collapsed somewhere
around the first time miami beach the
families are missing were allowed to
privately visit the
site for the first time sunday according
to miami-dade mayor
levine cava on saturday levine calva on
saturday ordered a 30-day audit
of all residential properties five
stories or higher that are 40 years
or older and fall under the county's
jurisdiction the
mayor encouraged cities to do their own
building reviews as well okay
adam you had a chance to go visit this
what's it looking like there right now
well can you pull it up so people can't
see the site of course this story i
think broke on thursday
yep and this story literally and
figuratively
hits close to home for me surf side is
just north
by the way people send me the video a
friend from uh years ago
sent me the video i looked at the video
i thought it was one of those prop
hotels that's coming down you know how
they that's exactly
right like yeah it's definitely so no no
this is not detonating a property
this is actually out of nowhere it's
just unexpected yeah
and um usa today does a good
um way
of basically showing what the building
was and what it is now and it was matt
it's like a
two a third of the building just
collapsed so i'm not sure if usa the
graphic that they have click on that
right there
click on that video right there three
days ago yeah there you go click on that
uh can we show this yeah we can show
this okay
no that's definitely not a shack but go
ahead keep saying and we'll go after
yeah so people just to put it in
perspective this is just
basically a mile north of what miami
beach proper is right so this is
surfside is in basically the 80s and 90s
just north in the 90s is what's called
bell harbor we were at the baja mall a
couple months ago saint regis
exactly all that my sister and my
sister's family lives right there in
belle harbor that's where i go
and stay on the weekends and see with my
family and i grew up just up the street
in north miami beach so this is
literally
um close to home and the mayor of bell
harbor which is the town
basically the next block over is one of
my closest friends gabe groysman he's 40
years old he's got five daughters
talking about a girl dad
he's a lawyer he's an attorney he's a
pro-israel um
very vocal person like that but he's
also the mayor of bell harbor
okay he was walking around with governor
desantis and just seeing what the hell
is going on here's a video just for the
audience to see look at that
yeah just a scary thought to see that
just
and then this tower comes down watch
this
yeah so the the problem that i have with
i mean this is a sad situation i i don't
know anybody directly that lived there
but a lot of good friends of mine had
family there like i've won
my buddy jared he was posting
you know please please pray for these
families i text them i said well
why do you know these people said these
are my five cousins who moved here from
puerto rico they're all dead
the problem that i have with the media
is when the story came out and i get
that there's a sensitive story
they said building collapses one person
dead
do you remember that story i do okay so
one person dead
now they're out there saying nine people
are dead and 150 something are people
are unaccounted for
what the hell do you mean unaccounted
for these people aren't traveling europe
right now not responding to their cell
phone
they're dead they're full on dead and
the the the problem that i had is
emotionally you hear this story there's
so much in the news right now oh one
person oh thank god only one person
no every single person in that building
would have been because if it wasn't
unaccounted for three hours get it maybe
they're coming back from summer what six
hours get it a week later
no unaccounted for yes come on man maybe
that might be a few
that's a scary thought by the way yeah
so what's really scary is that guy
thomas morbido in 2018 the engineer who
gave the warning about this and nothing
was done
yes so the the a crazy
how often that happens would they give
it and nobody goes and looks into it is
that a common thing
but here's the problem i have with it is
that you can you can make the excuse and
say okay
during 2020 maybe they couldn't really
do anything with co but yeah two years
before that
why was nothing done and you talked
about this earlier about
uh the majority of houses are 40 years
old
uh 1980 1981. now apparently you're i
mean you're the real estate expert
you've just you've taught us a lot today
apparently there's a 40-year
re-certification
of buildings this building was built 40
years ago in 1981 yeah
so something was up with this building
something
you know i don't know how it passed its
code i don't know what kind of fraud was
going on here
i think number one you know focusing on
the moment focusing on the now
cleaning this up but bigger picture like
we're talking about real estate we're
talking about south florida we're here
is they need to go at every single
building
yes and and figure this the hell out
because
you also talk about new yorkers who are
moving here in flux we were touching on
that earlier
a lot of people are looking at saying
you know i was considering maybe buying
a condo in south florida
maybe i was moving to south florida i'm
not so sure about that now because
you know climate change is real it's
happening whether it's man-made or not i
think that's a debate but you know
there's a rising tides here
imagine living in that building right go
back to the picture imagine you're
living in the building right next door
hey come home baby
yeah yeah hey i'll see you tonight like
imagine you're the one that's standing
what are you doing if you're are you
going back let me go get my stuff
upstairs i'm not doing it you go get it
how the hell do you sleep at night
like if you've got kids you're going to
be able to sneak up in there you're not
sleeping there
what do you do with all your stuff this
is up there all your well thank god
alive
number one thank god you're alive you
just got now now try reselling that i
don't that's condos try selling that
condo and adam's point about people
being a little skittish i mean you have
to look at age because this was a little
bit older number one and number two
if it's right on the water you get that
corrosive nature of it you know so maybe
it's a little bit further back a little
less to worry about but
this is definitely something that's
going to make people think twice about
well they were basically saying that
they went into the garage and they were
showing what the hell was going on down
there and there were cracks and it's you
know obviously the pool right there
so you look at this and look we've never
seen anything like this is insane
you it starts falling from the top and
then crack
but basically what i understand here is
the bottom
implodes and then the floor above that
follows and then the floor above that
it's like a pancake effect
so visually it looks like it's falling
from the top but no the bottom is
crumbling and then each floor boom boom
boom
so imagine a floor falling on top of you
and then the floor on top of that
falling on top of you
you're not surviving that i mean
it's insane here 152. uh
i wonder how long it's going by the way
the whole thing what you're saying is
there fraud i don't think it's fraud
there's a lot of
buildings you go to where the elevator
inspection is supposed to be done once
every 12 months and you see the
inspection some buildings haven't been
done for three or four years
it's just a lack of paying attention to
details right that's really all it is
you got a lot how many elevators in
america haven't been inspected on time
today
think about it a lot of them and how
many buildings like this you think they
haven't been inspected i bet there's a
lot in america that haven't been
inspected
so think about how many others are
sitting there thinking about this and
what about my building like
how many people went and knocked on the
property manager's door and saying hey
when is the last time we inspected this
in the last
week every single one of those oh not
just in miami i tell you there's a lot
of old buildings in america today
tenants are going to say hey johnny just
out of curiosity when do we last inspect
this building
when do we last inspected it's something
to be thinking about so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you